Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain an American coming-of-age
comedy-drama film called “Jack.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins at a Halloween party where
a young woman Karen Powell is dancing with
her husband Brian Powell.
Suddenly, Karen feels a sharp pain in her
stomach and steps aside from the dance floor.
Brian quickly gets to her and asks her what
is wrong.
It turns out that Karen has been pregnant
for a little more than two months but is going
into labor.
Brian and their friends rush her to the hospital.
The nurses do not believe her when she says
she is not due for another seven months.
The doctor comes in and calmly tells her that
it might only be some early pregnancy cramps
but is surprised to see her fully dilated.
With a deep breath, Karen pushes out a fully
developed baby boy.
She holds him in her arms and calls him Jack.
The doctors check Jack’s condition and find
out that he has an exaggerated form of Werner
syndrome.
Because of this, his cells are growing four
times faster than the normal rate.
Although he should be a two months old infant
right now, he is a fully developed nine months
old baby.
The doctor assures the parents that the kid
is perfectly healthy and in good shape.
He explains that nature has given all humans
an internal clock that meters our lifespan
and controls our growth.
Jack’s clock happens to tick faster than
others.
The condition is unheard of so it doesn’t
have any cure but they predict that if the
kid grows at this rate, he will turn into
a fully grown forty-year-old man at the age
of ten.
The parents are in utter disbelief.
Cut to ten years later, as the doctors had
predicted, Jack grows up faster than any human
and appears to be a full-grown man at the
age of ten.
Although his appearance affirms otherwise,
Jack is a child by nature.
His parents have never allowed him to step
out of their gated house scared that he will
get bullied.
The neighbor kids who have only got glimpses
of him through the window, consider him a
giant monster who eats children.
Lawrence Woodruff is Jack’s teacher who
homeschools him every day.
He is the only person who is close to Jack
other than his parents.
One day, Woodruff is trying to teach Jack
but he keeps on getting distracted by the
kids in the front of his house trying to get
a glimpse of the giant ten-year-old.
To mess with them, Jack throws a gooey eyeball
toy through the window.
Woodruff finally gets him back to study but
notices the sadness in Jack’s eyes.
After the class, Woodruff suggests to Karen
and Brian that they send Jack to school.
Karen, being the protective mother she is,
is against the idea.
Woodruff states that they can warn the principal
and prepare the kids for Jack’s arrival
to make it easier for him to fit in but the
parents are still against the idea.
In the evening, Jack and Karen play Marco
polo around the house.
When the game ends, Jack asks Karen if he
is really a giant monster.
He had heard the children talk about him during
the day.
Karen assures him that he is as normal as
any kid his age, which couldn’t be further
away from the truth.
Before going to sleep, Brian and Karen discuss
if they should really send their kid to school.
They are disturbed by Jack coming to their
room wanting to sleep with them because he
had a nightmare.
The following day, Jack is told that he is
going to school for the very first time.
He excitedly shaves his beard and puts on
his clothes.
Karen packs him food and they make their way
to the school.
They meet the principal McGhee who welcomes
Jack.
The parents wish him good luck.
Before leaving, Karen asks him to call her
anytime if he gets bullied.
The principal then introduces Jack to his
teacher Miss Marquez.
Jack shyly enters the class and stands in
front of his classmates.
The group of kids who were chased away by
him yesterday is also in the same class.
Miss Marquez introduces him to the kids and
asks him to take a seat.
Jack then sits on his seat which is too small
for him.
While trying to fit in, he falls off, making
the entire class laugh.
Even when he is provided a bigger seat, he
breaks it and the kids laugh even harder.
During recess, he is alone in the playground.
The children look at him and whisper to each
other about his controversial size.
The group of kids who he chased away the previous
day watches him in fear, believing that he
will probably beat them for bothering him.
The group leader, Louis, brings out the monster
eye from his bag and shows it to Jack but
quickly keeps it back inside.
Just then, a rival group challenges them for
a basketball match.
As Jack watches them play, two little girls
poke him with a stick and ask him how old
he is.
They make fun of his receding hairline and
his hairy arms.
After he sends them away, the basketball lands
near him.
He picks it up to throw it back but the rival
kids say they do not want to touch the ball
since it is probably contaminated now that
Jack touched it.
Louis and his group clearly feel bad for him.
Jack sulks when he returns home and doesn’t
eat his favorite food that Karen cooked.
Brian tells him about the day he first rode
a bicycle and points out how much he has improved
since.
Using the example, he makes Jack understand
that the children at school will eventually
open up to him.
The following day during lunch, Jack gets
into a tunnel to eat since he has no one to
eat with.
Miss Marquez feels bad for the kid and eats
with him.
Louis and his friends are challenged to a
basketball match yet again.
Since they are short on teammates, Louis invites
Jack to play with them.
For the first few rounds, Jack doesn’t understand
what he should do.
But as he gets a hang of it, he scores the
most and makes Louis’s team win for the
first time.
Following that, they are in Miss Marquez’s
class where she asks them to write an essay
about what they want to be in the future.
She pays extra attention to Jack because of
his specialties.
Jack, on the other hand, starts to develop
a crush on his teacher.
After school, Jack thanks Louis for letting
him play.
Louis, in turn, asks him for another favor.
He wants him to pretend to be the principal
in front of his mother Dolores so he wouldn’t
get in trouble for not doing his homework.
Jack is skeptical about the idea but Louis
doesn’t give him time to explain.
Dolores arrives at the school and introduces
herself to Jack, believing that he is the
principal.
She tells him that she has recently gotten
divorced and Louis is acting out because of
it.
As she talks, Jack only gives her one-word
answers.
He ends the conversation after claiming that
Louis is the smartest kid in the school and
she shouldn’t worry about him.
Before leaving, Dolores gives him her number
asking him out for lunch sometime.
Louis thanks Jack for having his back and
takes him in his group.
That day Jack returns home happier than ever.
He runs around the house and calls his father
at work telling him everything that happened
throughout the day.
On the weekend, Louis knocks on his door and
invites him for a sleepover.
Karen is surprised to see how quickly Jack
was able to make friends.
She allows the two to go over to Louis’s
home but they cycle back to a treehouse that
Louis and the group hang out in.
The other kids do not want to let Jack in
the group but Louis shows them the adult magazine
that Jack was able to get for him on the way.
Seeing that they can probably get a lot of
favors from him, they accept him into the
group.
They talk about girls and alcohol and have
farting competitions all night.
Meanwhile, Karen misses her kid since he has
been away from home for the first time in
ten years.
Brian finds her inside the box that Jack often
plays with and tells her that their kid growing
up is a good thing.
The following day at school, the kids take
a class picture for the yearbook.
Starting that day, Jack becomes an inseparable
member of the group.
They hang out at the treehouse almost every
day, go trick or treating on Halloween, and
Jack buys more adult magazines for his friends.
One day, he even brings Woodruff into the
treehouse and lets him in the group after
making him eat a gross smoothie bowl.
However, the treehouse cannot handle all that
weight and breaks.
As time passes, Jack grows older.
He starts to lose hair and go bald because
of which he uses black gel on his hair.
His classmates start to submit their essays
about what they want to be in the future but
Jack hasn’t decided yet.
A girl says she wants to get married by twenty-eight
but when Jack does the math, he finds out
he can only marry when he is one hundred and
twelve years old.
He mutters to himself that he wants to be
alive when he grows up.
After class, he asks Miss Marquez to be his
date for the dance.
As she tries to explain they cannot go together,
he kisses her.
Miss Marquez is taken back.
She bluntly tells Jack that he is just a child
so they cannot go together.
She apologizes to him but he breaks down crying
and runs away.
However, his day gets worse when he trips
and falls on the stairs.
He is immediately rushed to the hospital where
his parents come running, worried for their
son.
The doctor claims that Jack’s body has suffered
a severe strain because of the rate of his
cell multiplication.
Hence, his internal clock is starting to run
out, meaning he doesn’t have that many years
to live.
After returning home, Karen tells Jack that
they have decided to withdraw him from school
for his own safety.
Jack throws a tantrum because he doesn’t
want to be separated from his friends.
He begs Brain to let him go back to school
but the parents know they cannot allow that
after what happened.
At night, Karen and Brian are talking about
Jack in their room when Jack gets hold of
the matchbox that has Dolores' number and
the name of a club on it.
He sneaks out for the first time and visits
the club.
There, he meets a man named Paul and drinks
with him.
A while later, he meets Dolores and they start
to dance.
In the middle of it, she tries to make out
with him.
Jack remembers she is still his friend’s
mother and retreats.
He tries to get away from her but bumps into
a guy in the process.
The man is clearly drunk and starts a fight
with him.
Jack insults him, making the guy punch him
in the face.
At the end of the night, Jack ends up in jail
for trashing the club.
Dolores bails him out and drives him back
home.
Good thing for Jack, his parents are asleep
so he doesn’t get in trouble.
Two weeks have passed since the incident.
Jack has been sulking in his room all this
time.
His friends come to meet him every day but
he doesn’t come out of the house.
Karen calls Woodruff to their house in hopes
that he will persuade Jack to come out of
his room.
Jack talks to him and says that he doesn’t
want to learn stuff that he will probably
never get to use in his life because he won’t
live long.
Some days later, Louis gathers the entire
class in front of Jack’s house to call him
out to play.
The next day, Jack gets out of his room and
decides to go back to school.
His parents allow him to do so, seeing how
happy school makes him.
Everyone in his class is overjoyed to see
him back.
Seven years later, Jack and his friends are
at their high school graduation.
He is now much older with grey hair and wrinkles.
At the end of the movie, he delivers a speech,
in which he reminds people that life is short,
and urges them to make their life spectacular.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.